hey guys welcome to an episode of ask ij
i'm currently at home visiting my family
and i'm sitting on the floor in my
sister's bedroom it's real high-tech
shoot
and when i said hi-tech i was not
joking
and luck back here
so i hope everyone who celebrated
thanksgiving had a great thanksgiving if
you don't i hope that you had an amazing
week i actually had a lot of fun while
i've been home something happened that a
lot of you
including my family and friends have
been wanting to happen for a long time
and that is the furby my furby we shot
it all right
so don't actually shoot the target
right below wait i'm shooting the stump
she's shooting this right here all right
now the real question is do i post this
video because it's kind of disturbing
let me know if you think i should post
the furby shooting video say yes in the
comments or no in the comments so now
it's on to some questions our first
question is from ricky dillon hello
ricky how are you and he's wondering who
my favorite pokemon is now ricky i'm
really sorry to disappoint you but the
only pokemon that i know of is pikachu
so
so i guess it's gotta be pikachu preston
is asking what book do i recommend from
audible now as a lot of you guys know i
have an audible code it's audible.com
ijustine where you guys can go get a
30-day free trial and a free book and
it's funny that you mentioned this
because i have got a bunch of books that
i have mentioned in my past ij book club
on ij likes and i haven't had a chance
to listen to them so this past week the
only thing i have been doing is walking
around with my phone i'll sometimes even
stick it in my bra i'll stick it like
this and i will walk around the house
listening to my audiobooks and my
sisters are getting so annoyed
especially when i was listening to the
fall in our stars because it's kind of
sad in parts so i'd be listening to this
book and they're like stop it we don't
want to hear this we're like no but it's
happy it's a happy sad book
sort of even i was on the plane like
listening and i started crying got off
the plane crying so as for books to
recommend i don't really have a good
book to recommend because i just started
reading well having read to me in the
hunger games i saw catching fire and i
had no idea what was going on even
though i saw the first hunger games i
felt like i had to start reading the
books because there's so many questions
that i have and i'm super confused i
only have 10 hours and 15 minutes left
anyway audible.com slash hygiene link in
the description on to the next question
because i could be talking about my book
addiction all day matt and apple's
asking how old was i when i had my first
starbucks drink i actually have no idea
to be completely honest with you
surprising i don't have an answer to a
question tasan brewster is asking what
it's like to be me there's a lot of
traveling there's a lot of coffee
there's a lot of sleeping but then
there's also a lot of not sleeping
there's a lot of video production
there's a lot of days that i spend in
sweatpants and there's a lot of days
that i have to spend normal clothes
maybe if you watch some of my vlogs you
can get a small little taste i'm
planning on doing vlogmas which starts
tomorrow which is why i wanted to get
this video up before i start the vlogmas
check other ijustine youtube.com
jon jones is asking why i shot the furby
he got on my last nerve there's no off
button at all and there's none that's
why at night he would start talking just
talking in his sleep talking in my sleep
i would think i was going crazy but no
it was the furby greg wants to know and
me and jenna marbles are going to do a
video together honestly i want to do a
video i just don't know what we should
do so if you have any suggestions tweet
me and jenna and maybe we will work
something out
what am i going to bake next i feel like
that's always the question i mean it
really is and i just don't know maybe
i'll cook a furby pie
do i sing in the shower i do i sing in
the shower quite a lot but recently i've
actually been listening to audio books
in the shower i have this little
technique where i'll set it up like this
put a washcloth underneath of it and
then i just wrap it up so i can still
hear the audio and i can protect it i
should just put a lifeproof case on it
that would solve all my problems now
that i just thought about that that's
what i'm gonna do hey dana's asking for
like the hunger games trilogy i know you
know what i don't even know when i saw
catching fire i was so confused i'll let
you know when i finish my 10 20 like 30
hours of audiobooks joe wants to know
how am i so good at cooking it's all
about not following the recipes not
following anything just being yourself
and putting all of your heart and soul
into your ingredients and blending them
jill wants to know if i'm going to tour
around the united states and i would
love to actually i would need a reason
i would need a sponsor first of all
because traveling is extremely expensive
so oh boy
so many messages what was i even saying
i don't even remember a gamespot wants
to know what my favorite thing is about
the holiday season definitely the video
games so many games are out that i
honestly have not even had time to play
them like i just got zelda but then i
mean we have xbox and the ps4 and
there's games for each of those like
there's not enough time there's not
enough time and that's a really great
problem to have and there's too many
video games and not enough time well no
the best scenario would be all of the
time and all of the games to be able to
be played
stop ps4 xbox one says jake definitely
xbox one i have been actually using the
connect to record gameplay and it's kind
of cool you know some of you guys have
been complaining about the audio but you
know i'm sorry i'm sorry everything is
not perfect for you i try i try my
hardest but i will never be perfect
neither will anyone else which is a
great feeling if i could wax any
youtuber's leg
leguiza leg who would it be definitely
smosh i would love to just rip off all
the leg hair from ian and anthony and
just laugh it might be kind of painful
but it'll be worth it in the end promise
you guys oh i went to scroll down and
that's all the questions that we have so
thank you guys so much for watching this
quick little ask ij episode i hope you
guys all had an amazing holiday lots
more holiday cheer coming up let me know
um
what your favorite holiday meal is and
don't forget the xbox one giveaway is
still happening i'm going to pick a
winner this week uh watch my xbox one
unboxing for all of the details and i
will see you guys in my next video have
a great day i love you
peace out
you